[Music]
murder is this thing that we assume
we're not capable of until it happens if
you were to ask both people who end up
committing murder ten minutes or two
hours before the act happens they would
say I'm not capable of this the argument
escalates and it ends up in murder it's
far more likely for a man to be killed
by a stranger in a public place it's a
woman sort of meticulous killer who as
far as I'm concerned doesn't really
exist we all think we know what a killer
looks like a calculated psychopathic
stranger murderers like Jack the Ripper
or Ted Bundy who hunt their victims but
in reality these aren't the people you
should be most afraid of
Colleen Sutton I'm formerly a senior
investigating officer for the
Metropolitan Police murder squad there's
no question that the person most liked
to kill you if you're a woman is your
boyfriend your partner your husband not
a stranger walking across the path
without dark alley late at night the
most dangerous place for women to be
where she is most likely to be assaulted
or murdered is in her own home in fact
more than 40% of women killed in the
last five years died at the hands of a
partner or an ex-partner so what about
the psychopathic strangers we see in
movies while actually over the last five
years only 11% of female victims in
England and Wales were killed by someone
they didn't know 22 year-old Brenham
judah and her mother wala salim were
killed by her ex-partner in august 2018
ranim was on the phone to police when
John Barr serine stabbed her to death
her mother was killed trying to defend
her CCTV shows mr. tureen running away
the knife still in his hand it's
undescribable
it's
like me how I became calling you you
know it's it's heartbreaking I can tell
you know so to loved ones gone on all
night and we're all wondering why you
know you know what was it need to take
two lives of two beautiful personalities
most cases that we are called to where
we find a woman dead in a house it's
something that's happened spontaneously
it's a rage it's a fury it's not
something that say I need calculated act
it's something where an argument or a
disagreement has got out of hand and has
escalated and resulted in the murder
offenses like that are much more
commonplace than the premeditated murder
so what makes someone we love into a
killer my name is dr. Julia Shaw I'm a
criminal psychologist
the most common cited reason when we
asked men who have murdered their
intimate partners are that they were
jealous and that they found themselves
in what they often described as a fit of
rage when we look at the belief systems
that underlie this jealousy it's this
idea that women belong to men and that
they are effectively a form of property
that needs to be dominated and put
they claimed that it was almost out of
their control sort of she made me do
this why did she leave me why did she
why did she she she so it's putting the
pressure and the blame on the woman that
Beach was stabbing where there was a lot
of blood I've been to a strangulation
where there was no blood at all but what
was common between them was this sort of
chaotic nature and science has struggled
throughout the house
the murder weapon well people have us to
hand it could be a valise or something
heavy in the in the living room it could
be a knife if the kitchen is nearby
knives are used in a quarter of all
female murders in England and Wales and
in 20 percent of female homicides the
method of killing was strangulation but
that's not where it stops over killing
is when more violence is used than is
necessary to kill someone the 2017 UK
femicide census details how men killed
women that year Kerry McCauley was
battered virtually beyond all
recognition by her partner Jo story
every bone in her face was broken like a
jigsaw and her face was pushed inwards
by a centimetre the deadly attack
happened when Kerry tried to leave her
husband after a previous violent episode
in 2017 Karina Batista was stabbed 27
times and nearly had her spinal cord
severed her husband JC Rocha stabbed her
in the eye and heart before slitting her
throat he had become wrongly paranoid
Karina was having an affair in a number
of cases perpetrators also dismembered
and mutilated women's bodies after they
had killed them this horrifying level of
violence was used in more than 40% of
cases where an adult man killed an adult
woman in the UK in 2017
you'll see that there's more violence
being used and was necessary to affect
the murder where the attack has been so
savaged and protracted simply because
the man has been so angry and so unable
to control what he's doing through a
very few thankfully men who commit sort
of stranger random violence against
women in the street in public places but
interestingly when they do arise and
come up and when they're arrested and
when they're looked at it's found that
not only do they use violence against
women in the street but they'll also use
violence in the home against their
partner it's incredibly dangerous to
assume that we could spot someone who is
likely to murder their partner so I
think in general our creepiness radars
are completely off kilter we overly rely
on cues of things like attractiveness so
being more likely to trust someone
because they're attractive less likely
to trust someone because they're
unattractive so we need to be careful
not to assume that we can decide just
from looking at someone or from a short
impression of someone whether they're
dangerous to us or not well some
breaking news now and it concerns
another stabbing in London another knife
crime another stabbing in an area of
London a murder investigation has been
launched a man has been fatally stabbed
today and that a 15 year old boy has
been charged with murder the victim
suffered a fatal stab wound and despite
the best efforts of officers and
paramedics he sadly died at the scene
it's far more likely for a man to be
killed by a stranger in a public place
than it is all men
to get murdered by acquaintances or
strangers rather than those very close
to them men are much more likely to be
killed than women over the last five
years men were most commonly killed by a
friend or someone known to them such as
a neighbor
30% of victims died at the hands of a
stranger in England and Wales in
contrast to women under 5% were killed
by a partner or an ex-partner but
something is changing in 2018 there was
such a large increase in men killed by a
stranger that for the first time in five
years men were actually most likely to
be killed by someone they had never met
if you're a man you're most likely to be
killed by a man so the reasons why men
murder other men are typically because
an escalating fights because something
gets out of hands or territorial
disputes or gang-related violence or
other sort of sense of dominance show of
dominance so it's very different from
the reasons that men typically kill them
but where are these deadly attacks
happening most male homicides happen in
the street and in other public places
and these types of murders are on the
rise
there were 285 knife and sharp
instrument homicides recorded in the
year ending March 2018 this is the
highest number in England and Wales
since home office records began and
young black men are most at risk if one
of these gang members decide to what
about gang members I'll be off to all of
you go and all about them o'clock I want
these children to stop
[Music]
violence is something that men aren't
born with they're not born to be
violence just because they have
testosterone just because there's this
acceptance of male aggression instead it
seems to be largely a product of social
structures so it's this idea that we
socialize men in a certain way we
tolerate aggression we tolerate the
expression of violence in men more than
we do in women which makes them less
likely to inhibit themselves especially
in highly emotional situations murder is
this thing that we assume were not
capable of until it happens I would be
shocked if people who murdered someone
weren't themselves shocked that they
were capable of it
most people who murder only do it once
we know that it's actually one of the
crimes with the least amount of
reconviction we also know that most
people who murdered regretted ends
probably if you were to ask both people
who end up committing murder ten minutes
or two hours before the act happened
they would say I'm not capable of this
we see ourselves as good people we see
other people potentially as evil and
there's this barrier we create it's
really important that we understand how
regular human emotions like anger and
rage and jealousy and greed can lead us
into a situation where I think every one
of us is potentially capable of murder
it's not this external thing that we
can't understand if we don't think these
thoughts if we don't break into these
taboos we're never going to be able to
prevent it